well downing street says the spread of
the indian variant could pose a threat
to plans to ease all remaining lockdown
measures
next month from today anyone over
i think it's actually 36 can get
vaccinated
and the minister telling us earlier they
want to bring that down quite quickly so
it may well be 35 tomorrow
let's talk to the president of
epidemiology at the royal society of
medicine and a member of the independent
sage advisory committee
gabriel scali who joins us now good to
see you this morning
look in terms of where we're seeing
these pockets of indian variant
what do you think is the best way to try
to tackle that
i i think and at the moment the
pockets there are a lot of them 86 with
five or more cases but some of them
they're not all the same size and in the
areas like
bolton or blackburn where there are
significant numbers we
really should be throwing the kitchen
sink at this to try and get it down and
that means
the vaccination and it's great that
at last they've been given permission to
vaccinate people from
18 and over that's fantastic and that'll
make a big difference
but there are lots of other things
really good contact tracing
and finding of cases and support for
people to self-isolate
to stop the spread is really important
and
for some reason that it's not really
explained until now
england hasn't been testing people at
highest risk it hasn't been testing all
of the close contacts
but rather waiting for them to develop
symptoms before offering them testing
so that testing really good test and
trace for a change
is really what we need as well as that
we do need
a lot of vigilance and a lot of
information to the public so that they
understand that
the virus hasn't gone away it's still
there and it may be much much more
infectious
we also need to stop the importation of
it and that means
better border controls a proper
quarantine system we've been let down
badly by the large number of cases
that the uk has imported of this
dangerous variant
that was first identified in india so
there are a string of things that
that could be done and need to be done
okay look
you raise a whole host of issues there
firstly can we talk about the
vaccinations then
because quite what is happening in these
areas with surge vaccinations
seems to be unclear i mean it's
certainly not sanctioned by the
government i mean the ministers
are not saying that they're they're
approving this
so so who is approving this and can it
be done in more areas
well what is happening is that the local
directors of public health are taking
control
they haven't been given the power
previously they haven't been given the
resources to do their job
and that's why some of these communities
have found themselves in consistent
lockdown or consistent restriction
and the directors of public health i
think have lost their patience and
they're
starting to make the decisions and they
should be empowered to make these
decisions and they should be given the
resources
to do what's needed you cannot run this
pandemic from whitehall if we've learned
something
over the last year it is that we need
local response and it needs good
local public health action and local
public health decision making and that's
what we're starting to get
okay and then from a national
perspective i mean
england for this particular example
if it is necessary to try to stop this
let's say
highly transmissible variant from from
becoming dominant across
england and then the uk a local lock
down something which i mean although
regrettable you would support
well i think certainly local
restrictions
to get it under control but hopefully
we will be doing much more than just
putting on restrictions
sometimes it seems we're like a
one-trick pony the only thing we know is
shutting things down
and that's bad for people's health is
bad for the economy and it's a bad way
to tackle
an infectious disease we do need
outbreak control and that's a whole
range of measures
and that includes simple things like
improving the ventilation actually
putting some resources
into pain for better ventilation in our
schools
in our workplaces ensuring people have
fresh air and can stay safe
there's a whole lot could be done at a
local level
if they're given the power and the
resources i mean isn't there an argument
to say
local restrictions plus surge
vaccination at this time
could actually you know three weeks down
the line could have a huge impact
couldn't it
it could have a large impact and i i
this is
sort of classic public health response
to
an outbreak and an upsurge and we better
get used to it because we're going to
whatever
whatever we think we are going to
experience outbreaks and upsurges
of uh covet 19 going forward and we need
to get prepared
and we should look at this as something
that's going to have to be done
maybe for months to come whenever we get
these outbreaks or or
surges look we're almost out of time can
i ask you about the travel situation you
said more needed to be done to stop
things like the indian variant coming in
but i mean does that raise concerns for
you for
all international travel being opened up
even in the limited way that it has been
so far
well great concerns about this
particular variant because of its
much more transmissible characteristics
and it hasn't really taken off in europe
yet and if it takes off in europe i
think we're in for a very rocky time
because of course vaccination levels
are not at the same high level as they
are in the uk
in in much of europe and at the same
time
we're reducing travel restrictions and
many more people are
are disappearing off to on holidays and
will come back and not necessarily have
any
really managed quarantine and we know
self-isolation doesn't work
and i i'm really worried about
uh a big wave in europe if
this transmit very transmissible variant
or another one that comes along
uh can take off so a good quarantine
system on our borders
is absolutely essential gabrielle scally
good to see you thank you